this is a production of Cornell
University
so the topic of this presentation will
be surface ceiling and their effect on
the echo a dolla G of dry dry areas and
as Jeff services basically sums up my
PhD and a bit from my master studies so
if I would ask people what they know
about their sailing the majority of
people would say well they cause flash
floods in dry climates so last week we
had Becky's a talk about flash floods in
the Northeast but they also happen a lot
inter and drier areas and surface
sitting a one of the leading cause for
that and unfortunately they cause damage
the flood floods caused damage to
property sometimes even take lives and
basically a lot of times it's a
management problem but surface ceiling
is also a mechanism which mobilizes
water in environment where water is the
most limiting factor and up until now
that ecological role of surface sitting
has not been fully explored and this is
what I'm going to talk about so there
are setting for this presentation is
half a world away a Mediterranean this
is the coast of Israel yeah some of
lebanon syria jordan and i'm going to
take you to the south of Israel can you
see the cursor yeah over there and there
are research site that we worked on is
next to the village of la m and he'll
have in two villages and we worked on
this area where is it here all these
heels here below the forest there were
the study site and how it looks from the
ground basically like this you have a
rolling hills with a woody vegetation
patches of woody vegetation and in a
diffuse pattern and if you look closely
and just another view here you see that
surrounding all these patches are bare
areas okay so bare soil and if you have
a closer look even you can see so you
have a patch a shrub here and it's
surrounded by bare soil so bare soil in
these areas is usually sealed so it
might be filled by physical surface
sealing a or biogenic surface sitting on
a lot of times it's also both of them so
on this talk today i'm going to focus
only about the physical surface sitting
and not about biogenic another closer
look you can see it's a quite visible
you see the skin on the surface and it's
it's quite common in those area so how
does structural stock the visor for
sealing a care it's created by the
impact of raindrops on the exposed soil
aggregate and those eigen got to break
depending on the rainfall a kinetic
energy and some of this aggregate the
break-up just flows with the runoff but
some of it infiltrates in carries with
its fine particles okay so those fine
particles slowly increase the bulk
density of the disturbed soil layer and
at the end you have a layer which its
thickness could reach up to three to
four centimeter which much larger or
much the thickness is much bigger than
what usually people figured it's not
only the skin the visible skin on the
surface it can reach much deeper so
surface ceiling has been the topic of
research studies for poverty seventy
years now m and sixty years and most of
those early works of focused on
different aspects of surface ceiling and
des works were
mainly empirical you had run of plots
you had a lab lab experiments and over
the last 20 years there's been increased
attention and efforts to develop the
mathematical models of see the seal
hydraulic parameters and mostly led by
Schmoyer a saline which was one of the
instructors on this PhD work and when
you have the mathematical models you can
then start to implement surface sailing
into ideological models either either
different scale so it can be a hill
slope or watershed but you need to have
the mathematical models a few words
about a surface seating okay the sea
layer bulk density is a function of the
underlying soul a soil so here you have
you see the cursor you know this is the
row of the cross the row of the sea
layer it's a function of the original
soil the underlying soil below bellowing
and another Delta so this Delta depends
on soil type for a less soil is 0.4
centimeters and it decays on an
exponential rate and it basically looks
like this here on the X you have the
difference in bulk density on the way
you have the a thickness or the depth of
the soil of the sea layer excuse me so
this difference is maximized here on the
surface of the soil of the sea layer
it's 0.4 and then it slowly a decays and
till it converges with the underlying
soil for this graph here at the death of
two centimeters so another prominent
effect of the sea layer is of course on
the trolley conductivity of the soil
again the sealer connectivity stems
directly from the underline soy the
connectivity of the soil and and will
not go into all these parameters but
what it basically does is reduced
the interconnectivity is highly reduced
and just to demonstrate this this is a
comma less soil so on the bottom you
have the hydraulic conductivity versus
the head or the soy potential and a the
bottom graph is for the soil and the
upper one is for the sea layer and this
is the same okay so this is the soil and
this is the resulting sea layer from
this soil so if you just as you can look
at a case at ordem the maximum sign dalu
connectivity for the soil is around 3.3
centimeters per hour and the respective
sea layer it rally connectivity is
around 0.06 so the sea layer is about
one or two percent of the underlying for
the connectivity it's a huge contrast in
infiltration and that has of course a
remarkable effect on the hydrology and
sea layer is sometimes perceived as a
desert ification agent there's a highly
cited paper with over i think it's 160
citations now which place a surface
ceiling as an agent which accelerates
the certification and there's also a few
studies more recently that showed that
the sea layer has also some positive
effects on a ecology of dry land this is
the work of even of at Al which used a
round of model and he showed that a
surface feeling if you count for surface
feeling you have higher annual primary
for the primary production on the lower
topography on the bodies and another
work which is actually assigned a
project of my PhD we develop this a
runoff model and this is a
Pilates are not around the float on the
left you can see the topography so this
is high and this is low and basically
the water is flowing down from top to
bottom and on the right you see patches
of vegetation on this run of blood and
just for the size so you have the
perspective this is four meters wide by
I think it was yeah 18 meters a length
and this is what the cumulative
infiltration looks after 51 millimeters
of a storm so what you can see the blue
patches here are of course the
vegetation and the legend is the
cumulative infiltration in meters so if
you see for example here it's a blue
patch has roughly a around 20 a zero
point 28 of a meter which is about four
or five times of the rainfall amount if
you go even further down the Strand of
plot here this is a patch which receives
probably 10 meters of contributing area
and cumulative infiltration can reach
half a meter so it's like 10 times more
of natural rainfall and that's a huge
amount for vegetation in dryland because
water is there a limiting factor and and
this is basically places ceiling it's
what the literature called a non-local
control on the soil water content and
the vegetation water availability so the
water available for the vegetation here
results from water accumulating upstream
not in situ but there is also another
aspect for surface ceiling which was
rarely addressed in that you know the
lower permeability the lowest rollick
connectivity also affects evaporation
rates not only infiltration and here you
see a work for the years ago bressler in
their camper so they waited to soil
columns
one by rainfall and one by flooding and
they measure the community with
Appalachian over time and you can see
that for the rain treatments which
resulted in crusting and ceiling on the
top is has lower evaporation over time
and this effect was mainly disregarded
so it's possible that the sea layer also
has what they called a local control in
situ by affecting the evaporation rates
but this was not studied so the research
gaps for today's presentation what is
the sea layer local control on soil
water content and what is that effect on
vegetation water availability yes so in
the literature sometimes they call it
crafting sometimes they call it feeling
crusting is more usually associated with
the biogenic crusting but it's it's
basically similar ok so this research
questions were addressed using two
operational steps first we developed a
1d bare soil history of scale model
accounting explicitly for surface
ceiling so this is a simple model we
neglect neglect vegetation and it's a 1
b model so we don't have run off and we
don't have subsurface flowing the second
step was to develop a 2d model which
does account for of course so for
sailing and also vegetation water optics
so we include vegetation into the model
and the study cited as I said before was
next to live in we chose a hill slope
the semi that climate is semi-arid close
to 300 millimeters per year and it has a
distinguished wet and dry season so all
rain falls during the winter and summer
is hot and dry the soil Center study
psyched are brown little Souls and
less and we our model had three by three
meters resolution so it's basically a
vector of a fishnet of sales over this
hill slope and we characterize each cell
with an extensive soil database so what
we collected we had the soil death
measured in 550 location at this yield
slope and basically taking a 5 kilogram
hammer and placing this medal wedge and
it's quite painful and done that 550
times with a crew of helpers of course
not by myself and then I interpolated it
into a continuous layer so I can array
assign that that's the So Def to their
respective model cell we had soy texture
collected at 60 location at the hill
slope and analyzed for a detector and
that enable us to do continuous layers
of the send the silt and clay content a
hauling in gear statistics in kriging we
had a DM which was measured on the site
i used the total station to record the
height of the hill slope in 700 was that
very point eight points all along the
seals opened that after interpolation
led for 20 centimeters a DM which
relatively high resolution and once you
have the DM you can calculate the
radiation for each cell and the
inclination of the cell I further used
classification I had higher solution
classification to extract the percentage
of the rock outcrops in each module cell
and I corrected the water availability
for the soil in the remaining in the
remaining soil in that cell and
some factor which we corrected so as I
said before which attention is not
accounted subsurface flow is not
accounted for and run Randolph is not
accounted so all of this database was
fed into Hydra Swan be I don't know if
you're familiar with hydras or not
hydros is a numeric subsurface flow a
software and we had two cases we had
either a field a sale or an unsealed
sale so if we had a sealed case we
applied the wily minister in equation
from the W allow 1989 paper and we
developed the matlab code which
basically automates this say a model
throughout these entire sales and ending
with possible to predict or model theta
the volumetric water content in every
location at the seal slope or any depth
that you want a few words about the
hydro this is how those independent
cells a look at the hydrous a 1d
software so this is the soil column and
if for the field case we had also a
two-centimeter sea layer here which is
characterized by the color soy
parameters of the underlying soil okay
so each one each cell was related
directly the sea layer to the soil in
itself a Hydra solve numerically the
richest equation and which I brought
here but I will not go over it it uses
the water retention above the soil in
the sea layer and it's a very widespread
ideological software hydras eyes of a
check last month there was 1300 papers
which have used hydras since the late
90s and all of them are available at the
company website it's a very versatile
tool very strong tool so
every model needs to be validated so we
done it in 82 his supplications before
and after every rainfall event of the
2010-2011 rainfall season 817 water
content measurements each one is a a
verge of free replica so basically I
took to the lab to it's a gravimetric or
the content sampling okay so i took the
soil and weight it and place in the oven
for two days and then wait it again and
basically cross the 2500 soil samples
which i took from this a cube and this
is the result so quite a bit of
scattering okay you can get the model to
work anymore that I guess you can get it
to work sometime eh or even most of the
time but you can't really get it to work
all of the time any model that you do
and over here on the y-axis you have the
simulated so on a what the content
versus are measured and we can see two
ranges here so all these measurements
here which has a higher water content
there were all samples right after the
rainfall events okay so during that time
a the soil moisture viability is high
and the model it was harder for him to
get it right but still if you look at
the overall accuracy and efficiency have
enough suta suta cliff efficiency of 0.7
so the model works but still a lot of
scattering if you look at the lower soil
water content measurements you can see
here the sea layer of course
measurements are
in the blue and unfilled are the red and
what you see that if you do not account
for ceiling in your model you basically
underestimate soil moisture measured at
the field okay and you can see it quite
clearly here and we wanted to further
explore this so this is just an
averaging although those measurements in
time so on the Y the water content and
on the X is the simulation time the
black circles are the measured data than
average measure data of the hill slope
and the green is the sealed case and the
brown is the unsealed one and as I said
before you can see that during the
drying intervals between the rainfall
events are basically an unsealed soil
dries quickly and underestimates what to
measure that the field and and what
happens is that during the evaporator
the drying interval the sea layer
reduces also dive operation from the
soil and basically keeps higher water
content below it so I'm going to
demonstrate it from some model outputs
this is I on the left you have the
sealed heels of the sealed case on the
right you have the unsealed one and the
water content the legend of course you
have the warmer colors for dry and the
blue colors for width and here below you
can see it's just an extract from a
season this is a 2016 11 and I'm just
stuck the model in a right after a
rainfall event I'm not going to show
what's happening when you start the
drying interval so as days go by
basically the unsealed so it drives much
faster and after a week or two
completely different water content map
on the hills
so we wanted to explore when is this
happening and why and we i'm going to
show free a free slide the first one is
what happened if you have a seven
millimeter rainfall event on the hill
slope seven millimeters per hour so this
intensity does not generate runoff okay
in our study site and if you start the
simulation from the same initial water
content you can see the water quantity
increases but then it drops and it
remains higher for the field treatment
the suitcase here on the blue and by the
time the next week for the event arrives
of course the sea layer because there's
no runoff there's no loss of order so
the water content increases a higher to
higher water content for the sealed case
and it remains higher so if you had only
low intensity rainfall event you
basically have always better conditions
under a field where a conditions what
happens if you have stronger rainfalls
so for the top figure you have a
rainfall of 15 millimeters per hour and
this arranged for generated twenty
percent of runoff so for the first days
after the rainfall event you can see
here the the blue excuse me the red
unsealed case has higher water content
okay so you have run off lost four in
the sealed case what they did not
infiltrate and as a result it has lower
water content but after a few days five
days for example in this case this is
reversed and basically what the sealer
does it compensates for all this water
lost by runoff by reducing evaporation
rates during the drying intervals and by
the time the next rainfall event arrives
again the sea layer the field system is
favorable in terms of water content and
will remain favorable until the end of
the season but what happened if you have
a higher intensity
iful event let's say 24 millimeters per
hour so this rainfall event leads to 50
a around fifty five percent of runoff
and for the given drying interval here
for a week the sea layer there's so much
water which is lost to run off so the
field system just remains dryer until
the next rainfall event it cannot
compensate for such a large loss of
water and so it's a complex pattern
because every rainfall throughout the
season of course has its own intensity
and drying a interval until the next
rainfall event and on the long term this
is the average of 32 years of simulation
for that study site you can see that the
sea layer which is on blue has higher
water content than the unsealed one this
these are all individual sales 8,000
sales is plotted here and what also is
important to notice that's on the y-axis
you have the temporal standard deviation
so this means how much does the soil
must change in time okay um and what you
can see that the silly are not only has
higher soil soil water content in the
sealed case it also has lower standard
deviation tempo a standard deviation so
what the content is higher and it stays
there for longer of time compared to an
unsealed case and this of course can
possibly have a large effect on water
availability for vegetation which are
surrounded by a ceiling and this is our
next step this is the next second part
of this presentation so how does that
affect what your availability to address
this we have used a unique setting
climatic setting in Israel where over a
short distance you have a sharp climatic
gradient over
around 40 miles we have 200 millimeters
climatic gradient so you can basically
we have here free meteorological station
naha watch with the the setting which I
showed before another middle one here in
Beersheva and the Booker at the south so
we use data from free climatic from free
metrological station and another unique
setting is that all of the staff of
Israel was exposed to Aeolian deposition
and the creation of less soil extensive
less soil so basically we can use the
same soil type okay on all of these a
analysis so the only thing that would
differ was the climatic condition so
that made it easier for the analysis
okay so back to the hydros model and
hydras this is a tool to the richest
equation and the way in hydras or the
way the region's equation implement the
vegetation is by a sink term this s here
okay and what is the sink term you have
to define it using a water aplic model
the hydrous offers you a few to choose
from the most of a common one is the
FedEx what after k model and i will go
over it briefly so the s the sink term
is a function of alpha which is a
reduction coefficient I will explain in
a second and which is x my lost my
cursor here here multiplying by
potential transpiration which you assign
for a simulation and that defines how
much of that potential transpiration is
been thinking like transpired by the
shrub or removed from the simulation
sale okay so what is the in briefly what
is the fairest water optic model on the
Y here you have the reduction
coefficient it ranges from 0 to 1 on the
X this is the water potential
this is saturation here on the left and
it goes dries as you go here further to
the right and under a saturated
condition you have anoxic a condition
you have very basically very little
transpiration so the reduction
coefficient is minimum on high
saturation very quickly when the the
potential decreases and you have a drier
soil and this becomes optimal and it
remains optimal until a point which is
defined a p2 point where it starts to
decline in this model it's linearly
declines until it reaches to the point
of p3 which is a stops transportation so
that's like represent a wilting point
okay and and of course the location of
the potential the soil water content on
which p2 occurs and p3 occurs our
vegetation specific so now we have a
challenge if i was to model corn i have
a good life it's very easy in the
commercial crop everyone or not there
when a lot of people have studied it and
you can just pick up from the literature
order form to that you want and go on
and model it but if you want to model
natural vegetation or psychopathy ileum
spinosum which is the the main shrub at
the study site it's just not available
there is no you can't take corn and say
it's equivalent because it's not so we
had to calibrate and basically a measure
those parameters and we did it using a
lysimeter experiment small-scale my soul
mate and lysimeter experiment where we
had the shrub we grew it in a hothouse
screen housing for a year and we planted
it in buckets where we know all the dry
weight of each component and
we place it on high resolution scales I
know if you can see it so this scares
away that the weight of the bucket and
since we know what the dry weight of
other components all the difference
stems from soil moisture in this bucket
and you can track that the dynamics of
water content within each bucket but now
we have a problem okay so we went to the
study site and we brought soil from the
study site and repacked and we planted
that the buckets the shrubs in the
bucket but once you take soil out of
your study site you interfere with all
these parameters and you basically
repack it in there in the in the bucket
and you don't know what now the soil
parameters are and the sole parameters
will affect the parameters which you
calibrate for the vegetation they all
interact with each other so we did it in
a two-step procedure first we calibrated
only the soil parameters which we packed
in the same way and use that a with a
hydrous 1b version an inverse
calibration procedure and with a
cumulative evaporation as the objectives
and it's basically quite a good
calibration and so now after we have
that we have the destroyed parameter so
we can take them back into the more
complicated case of vegetation in the
bucket and calibrate the shrub water
uptick below metals so again we did that
using hydrous one day we had fifteen
different data sets of a wedding and
drying and recalibrated a five-phase
reduction coefficient parameters I used
a Latin hypercube sampling approach with
to generate 20 different files and
parameter sets which were used for the
calibration so we can calibrate in a
high-resolution way
so these are the results on the top you
have the calibration range on the bottom
have the resulting of the foot parameter
set and on the bottom you have the
validation of this calibration which was
quite well so a note here those p 2
points the people value in the p3 which
define the onset of stress in this
vegetation on the wilting point these
values here are the results of the
calibration assumptions that we made
okay because we director the drying
interval between the the wedding events
was the average drying intervals was
eight days between each a wedding event
so that was the average drying interval
of the study site that's why we chose
that and this p free value which is
basically a fifteen hundred centimeters
does not reflect the actual stress in
dash of the shrub we did not measure
anything related to stress we don't know
if there's actually onset of stress in
the shrub but we do know that that's the
optimal solution for the average
conditions and of this vegetation study
site and also we wish in the paper we
show that the ninety percent of all
available water is consumed between this
eight days so most of the water of the
from is from the first eight days and in
reality in the field it also can extract
water from cracks and the underlying the
bedrock and and it has all kind of
mechanism which enable him to survive
under dry condition but most of the
water is consumed in the first few days
of course after the rainfall event
the cumulative a ET the community
evapotranspiration and we partition it
between potential evaporation and
potential transpiration okay so we took
these parameters and this is a hydrous
2d transact it's a the blue layer
represent the seal and the orange is a
root zone uniform root zone which is
surrounded by a sea layer so this is for
the sealed case of course if you is no
still for the answer one just continuing
soil there's no silly and these are two
points to observation points which I
will talk about in a few slides and this
is the boundary conditions for the
simulation so I developed this ratio
which I call the vegetation water optic
Roger which basically the cumulative
uptake for the field case over the
cumulative optic for the unfilled one so
if it's higher than one the sea layer is
beneficial for vegetation if it's lower
than one it's a negative factor and I've
used 35 years of climate data from in
each of those stations some station I
had 40 let's double calcite but some
less but overall few decades I've
climate data and this is the results so
the line represent the one the
vegetation water optic value of one and
the vast majority of all seasons a
surface ceiling is a positive factor
increasing vegetation water uptake and
the average is an increase of twenty-six
percent okay so that's quite significant
for of course if those vegetation order
the dry land vegetation you can see that
this effect is not a uniform across all
station and the black ones represent the
the semi-arid sight of love a witch the
sea layer doesn't have a less effect as
a reduced effect and as the season as
the station goes dryer the sea layer
effect increases and also the scattering
increases but you can reach for the
debacle side a vegetation what the
uptick of close to fifty and sixty
percent so that's a huge increase in
uptake and how is this happening I will
explain that using the observation
points there we find the root zone we
have point number one and just outside
the root zone we have point number two
and this is the water content ratio
means that the water content are the
sealed system over the unsealed one if
it's higher than one what the content is
higher for the sealed case and this is
one at 1994 season and they'll have them
site and you can see the during the
rainfall event here and okay so this is
the water content ratio and this is the
time and the black lines are the
rainfall event here so during these
rainfall events due to run of initiation
so what the content is lower but a
sealed case if the ratio is lower than
one but as the drying interval proceeds
and the water content ratio is higher
for the seal case and it's much higher
for point number two which is outside of
the root zone and it's close to twenty
percent higher so this is what drives
the water content uptick of the shrub of
has a higher water availability another
interesting observation is that the
relation between the surface ceiling and
the annual rainfall amount is non unique
so in this say dotted rectangular shape
which I in a draw here you can see that
for the same seasonal rainfall amount
you can have multiple solutions of
vegetation water optic so what's
happening here and what's happening that
we feel season rain
characteristics are highly important and
they actually drive the water content
uptick and the vegetation water cup the
karate and I'm going to demonstrate it
here here you have a a low initial water
content condition the state of zero
point 12 and you have to rainfall
intensities one is six millimeters quite
low in one is 24 millimeters quite high
per hour and what you get is for this
low water content the initial water
content condition you have so much
runoff generated that basically the sea
layer is negative it has low vegetation
what the optic right you're lower than
one and it stays lower than one even if
you have a prolonged drying interval but
if you have do the same exercises same
simulation it's just started from a
higher water content initial condition
so at the beginning of the simulation
because of the runoff water content and
vegetation what your optic is lower for
the field case but after a few days it
starts to increase so it also depends on
the initial water content condition on
the rainfall intensity and on the drying
interval so this is one storm and over
an average season in a study site we
have roughly 13 storms so in each one of
those the filler can either be a
positive and negative and this
accumulative effect leads to this
non-uniqueness that we've seen in the
previous graph so I've close to
finalizing this presentation the we
wanted to also prove or show that these
results are applicable on different
serial thicknesses in reality the seed
layer thickness is the
ended on the rainfall in energy during
for kinetic the soil organic matter the
soil type within the same you stop it
can vary and it actually varies on the
field the thickness so we repeated this
analysis for different soil AC layer
thickness and we basically see that it's
enough to have half a centimeter of a
sea layer to have a significant effect
on vegetation water uptick and basically
a of course if you have a higher or seal
thickness a larger field sickness that
they effect increases so basically it's
applicable across different sea layer
thicknesses conclusions surface ceiling
okay is responsible for floods they
cause property damage and might be a
negative factor but it also has an
essential role in the delicate Ecuador
elegy of dry climates this effect varies
between storms between soil properties
but overall under most conditions
surface sailing is a positive local
control it increases the salt water
content and its persistence over time
this increased word availability leads
to higher vegetation water uptake which
increases on the long run vegetation
resilience in those a dry climates so
we've seen the sea layer has both a non
local control and vegetation and a local
control and that places it as a key
player in the Ecuador geo dry climates
where water is the limiting factor thank
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu